it's often hard to tell which movies
will be big hits and which ones are
destined to flop but the 2019 film
calendar has a number of potential major
duds in waiting
be glad your salary doesn't depend on
any of these films making money and get
ready for a sneak peek at the biggest
box-office bombs of 2019
serenity certainly has a lot going for
it it stars a list Academy Award winners
Matthew McConaughey and Anne Hathaway on
screen together for the first time since
interstellar but even their beautiful
multimillion-dollar mugs are no
guarantee it'll make Bank sure
McConaughey has evolved from his rom-com
in EDTV phase but the Makana sense has
still been spotty at the box office
unfortunately serenity will most likely
continue this trend mostly because the
movie looks well indescribable weird
movies are fine but they don't lead to
box office glory and serenity doesn't
just look bizarre it looks baffling the
trailers defy comprehension and
consequently nobody can tell what it's
about moviegoers want to have at least
some idea what they're spending their
bucks on come January 25th it probably
won't be serenity on the plus side its
competition that weekend seems pretty
light but it's also going up against the
second weekend of M night Shyamalan
smutch anticipated blast that movie is
about as mainstream as it gets and as a
case study in how to market strange
material so no matter how much fun in
the Sun serenity offers its outlook
doesn't look bright Terminator Titanic
and Avatar auteur James Cameron is
producing Alita battle angel along
gestating sci-fi adventure based on the
famous post-apocalyptic manga meanwhile
director duties go to former indie
darling turned Spy Kids creator Robert
Rodriguez who's helming the 200 million
dollar film adaptation if you're getting
a last airbender or ghost in the shell'
vibe from the trailers you're not alone
Airbender made money ghost not so much
Aleta seems more like the latter with
its pg-13 rating likely to turn off fans
of the violent source material while
doing nothing to lure in the kiddos
there's also Rodriguez whose last film
was 2014 mega turkey sin city a dame to
kill for Rodriguez is notorious for
stretching a dollar he made his first
movie el Mariachi for just seven
thousand dollars but this movie's budget
is about 28,000 times that it's one
thing for your movie to make money
because it was so cheap to produce it's
a whole different ballgame to turn a
profit on a 200 million dollar
investment chances are you can look for
this to bomb stateside when it hits
theaters on February 14th with producers
hoping it'll perform well overseas and
if not at least James Cameron has his
for avatar sequels to look forward to
so captive state looks tremendous clever
concept compelling visuals John Goodman
Vera Farmiga any one of those is enough
to earn our money even so it may not be
enough to make this blend of horror and
sci-fi action a hit and you can blame it
on scheduling captive State was bumped
from August 2018 back to March 29th 2019
where it will go up directly against Tim
Burton's Dumbo the first of many Disney
live-action remakes next year captive
state has a great pedigree in Rise of
the Planet of the Apes director Rupert
Wyatt
but high-concept sci-fi is hit or miss
for every district 9 or 10 Cloverfield
Lane there's a Jupiter ascending or City
of a thousand planets federal agent on
duty reveal sci-fi is a risky bet even
under the best conditions but against
Tim Burton and an adorable flying
elephant that's tough
captive state may have a chance at
counter-programming but only if it's
really good we've all been burned by
incredible trailers for bland movies
so hopefully captive state won't follow
that trend you and I both know those
days are gone be aware of Oscar bait
movies that come out in the spring as a
general rule Oscar season usually starts
in the fall with the notable exception
of Best Picture winner crash springtime
message movies rarely make a dent in the
public consciousness let alone the box
office take the best of enemies for
example slated for an April 5th release
the film is about a civil rights
activist played by taraji P Henson who
co-chairs a community meeting about
school desegregation with a KKK leader
played by Sam Rockwell surprising nobody
the experience changes both of their
lives it sounds like either a really
saccharine made-for-tv movie or a really
twisted SNL skit but it's actually based
on a true story
Henson recently starred in the
oscar-nominated blockbuster hidden
figures as well as the award-winning hit
TV show Empire Rockwell meanwhile
recently snagged an Oscar for his
supporting role in free billboards
outside Epping Missouri and has
consistently proven himself a versatile
character actor hopefully the star power
will be enough to give the best of
enemies a fighting chance at the box
office but more likely the best of
enemies will disappear from theaters
just as fast as every other awards
contender released in April the New
Mutants is about a group of teenage
mutant superheroes who aren't Turtles
so that's already a huge mark against it
not helping matters is the confused
genre splicing of horror and superhero
action in what will be the 13th film in
20th Century Fox's x-men franchise take
a moment to consider how much of your
life you've spent watching x-men movies
to its credit the series hasn't been
overly cautious about mixing genres the
comedy superhero hybrid Deadpool
spin-offs have made millions of the
domestic box-office and are the highest
grossing films in the entire x-men
franchise but those films had a huge
plus factor in their favor people
actually wanted to see them join us use
your powers out be a superhero the
reception for the new mutants was much
more muted the incredibly dark murky and
dreadful trailer even had some fans
mockingly saying it looks like a DC EU
movie which are fighting words in the
superhero genre is there really an
appetite for a hostile esque x-men movie
not long ago Will Smith could star in a
dog shampoo commercial and it would be a
surefire hit but a string of bad bland
and just plain bizarre choices has
damaged the fresh Princess bankability
and perhaps more importantly his
credibility which brings us to Gemini
Man which is being held by Angley more
importantly it reunites Smith with his
bad boys an enemy of the state producer
Jerry Bruckheimer now back up put the
gun down and give me a pack of tropical
fruit bubblicious the story an older
hitman faces off against a young clone
of himself
sounds like a lazy looper ripoff except
Gemini man was in development for 20
years before being greenlit maybe there
is a reason for that it certainly feels
like a movie that would have been fresh
in 1997 Gemini man won't light the
box-office on fire but should at least
get plenty of play on basic cable
because when it comes to movies there
life after death it's called the TNT
Network
[Music]
here's the latest attempt to get the
Terminator franchise back on track
you're probably thinking wait another
one didn't terminate her whatever bomb
it did Terminator Genisys was a dud in
2015 in the US anyway it made enough
overseas to justify another trip to the
post apocalypse every new Terminator
movie is basically another attempt to
resurrect an aimless franchise honestly
the most interesting thing this series
could do is send the t800 back in time
to stop these movies from being made and
that's exactly what it sounds like it's
going to happen t6 is supposed to be a
direct sequel to t2 with rise of
machines salvation Genesis and the Sarah
Connor Chronicles wiped from history you
can do that with a time travel movie
right Linda Hamilton is even returning
as Sarah Connor and James Cameron is
producing and contributing to the story
that's good enough for a little interest
and hopefully it'll be enough to save
the film from bombing harder than
Judgment Day
[Music]
big-screen musical adaptations are
pretty hit or miss at the box office
sure Chicago did pretty well financially
but you can't say the same for Rock of
Ages or rent and while Andrew Lloyd
Webber is one of the most bankable names
on Broadway and the West End his film
record isn't nearly as impressive good
cats in that string of box-office
blandness it's based on one of his most
popular musicals and features perhaps
his most famous song memory however his
most popular musical and Broadway's
longest-running show was the Phantom of
the Opera which only scared up 51
million dollars in change in the US
theaters there's also the fact it's
coming out on December 20th 2019 the
same day as a quiet little indie drama
currently known as Star Wars Episode
nine with that kind of box-office
competition chances are slim that crowds
will show up to watch a bunch of dancing
cats